Será que o que você come durante a
gravidez pode até mudar o sexo do bebê?
Olha só essa descoberta bombástica que
saiu na Nature. Pesquisadores japones
descobriram que camundongos com
deficiência grave de ferro na gestação
tiveram bebês geneticamente masculinos
que desenvolveram órgãos femininos. Pois
é, a falta de ferro silenciou o gene que
determina o sexo masculino. Seis de 39
filhotes machos nasceram com ovários
completamente formados. Veja bem, ainda
não sabemos se acontece em humanos, mas
já é um alerta gigante. A nutrição na
gravidez pode ter impactos que a gente
nem imagina no desenvolvimento do bebê.
O ferro não é só para anemia, não. Ele
pode estar envolvido em processos
fundamentais que nem suspeitávamos.
Por isso que pré-natal bem feito é
fundamental e suplementação tem que ser
individualizada sempre. Me conta aí,
você sabia que a nutrição podia ter esse
poder todo? M.